ty roots just water please have a seat
here my friend how you defy you feeling
man dude I'm feeling good I'm feeling
full of love I am feeling so good I am
feeling just embraced and I hope we can
make you feel the same way my thought is
ending the show right that's like why
are we coming on it is silly no you know
because I think when we look looking
back at times we've spent n times we've
had in stuff we've made is obviously
really wonderful but this is also a
place it looks forward a lot and it's
something that I over the over the
course of many years here and working
with many different people looking
forward is as can be as invigorating and
as exciting as looking back so we're
gonna do that in a second but first tie
yeah I want to talk about your tenure
here at gamespot because you came on
just about three years ago three years
ago yeah and you came into a pretty
dynamic time here at gamespot it's one
way to sound a good word choice dynamic
yeah so talk to us a little bit about
how you came in and sort of really
started to make an impact here on our
video scene yeah um I mean I don't want
to we don't have to go to in the detail
about the dynamic miss sure of my
arrival quad obviously was a very I
think tough time for everybody here I
think there were a lot of changes
happening I was scared shitless you know
I was coming into an environment where
like you know I did not come from IGN
directly but I did come i had worked
there six years and then I worked in
dead for almost two and then coming back
to games media that was interesting
especially to like my arch nemesis oh
yeah yes um but actually no it was it
was scary was frightening but when I
came here I think my goal was just to
get to know everybody as well as I
possibly could and to establish you know
a production workflow and the types of
videos that we produce that I think
we're all proud of and that we want to
celebrate the medium know and really get
people excited about games and and focus
on what I think people like to watch and
it was it was hard because I think we
had to get the right people right and it
was a slow process of you know Mary was
already here
I got here but I think you were just a
contractor right so we yeah technically
um technically you worked here longer
than me in the sense that I was here but
I wasn't full time yeah so ty was my
best friend ty was gonna get me hired
yeah yeah I yada I for people and he was
always fighting a lot of battles behind
the scenes a lot of things that none of
us would ever were never really meant to
see or understand i was always back
there woody fighting somebody to get to
get people hired or to get the tech the
equipment that he wanted or the leverage
that he needed so that we could do our
jobs and he had to win every one of us
over individually because when he
started not a lot of people liked to
high no I was very true um but again I
think it was just at the time in which I
came in there are a lot of changes
happening at gamespot and it's no secret
that you know the are you know games
media like the way that we are now is
just it's changing every day every year
like it just something different happens
you know YouTube is such an
insurmountable beast right now at this
point so a lot of a facebook video is
now is surging hugely which has sprung
up and you know any immense popularity
in this time that you've basically been
here yeah it's it's a it's a dynamic
landscape it's shifting all the time
like you said and so I mean do you have
any sort of things that you sort of
point to in your your time here has sort
of like favorite memories or times that
you were like like yeah we nailed that
one or like man it was fun doing that
well I think a lot of it was learning a
lot from the people who were already
here before me you know so talking to
Dan Warrick talking to Ryan Mac talking
those guys and learning how they mean
these guys have been here forever right
so I really wanted to get an idea of who
the team was that I was that was already
here that had been doing video at
gamespot for you know a decade and then
how to grow upon that right and so I
learned a lot from Dan learned a lot
from Ryan you know jam Benito all those
guys I just try to develop relationships
with and work on how we can move forward
and I really wanted to focus on not
being a Content farm not making just
stuff
for the sake of making stuff right so I
wanted to focus on the people that were
here and I knew that Mary was great I
mean bringing her on full-time was a
no-brainer bringing Rob on full-time
no-brainer talking with you you know
like I mean by the way one of my shining
moments here is just realizing the
amount of puns you could whip out of
your mouth at any given moment it's a
gift that not many have I hope you
enjoyed the Pokemon segment or absent
yeah absolutely so I think it was just
plain to people's strengths right and
knowing what people love and want to do
and then taking their core strengths and
never putting somebody or doing my best
at least not to put somebody in a
position where they had to talk about
something they didn't know about you
know I wanted us to focus on games and
the content that we liked and that we
love we know and and you've kind of seen
gamespot now like kind of branching off
into entertainment that's because we
like all sorts of medium right and we
want to focus on other things but for
the most part we are we are at game site
and I want to make sure that whoever is
making content whoever's producing
content they're putting their heart and
soul behind it and it was hard it was a
hard change because it's not it's not
the easiest thing to convey to like our
corporate overlords you know but but
they were behind me you know and and I
and I won their support and slowly but
surely you know we always have to do you
know we out we out we have to get views
obviously but the ideas I still wanted
to believe we could get traffic and make
the content that we love and that has
that's you know the perpetual challenge
that I think has you know defined
gamespot throughout its existence and
that challenge has changed you know you
know especially with the the rise of
video but it's really been exciting to
not just be part of the team of the
video team you know you know when you
came on i was reporting to you and doing
video stuff and then i moved on to the
other sponsored side of stuff but to
sort of see how that's evolving and see
you know where it's going in the future
because this staff that we have you know
that there's a lot of you know people
sort of tend to comment on oh this
person who i know from way back is going
away but yeah when i started when i
started on the Edit team and i was
writing reviews now showing up it was
who the hell are all these people know
any of them you know ever today's newbie
is tomorrow's veteran and so i think
that you know this be true speaks to
what you said if you know gamespot has
been a site that has
gathered people to it that are
passionate about games and that do sort
of put that in and you know recognize
like on one level this is a job we gotta
do stuff we got to make stuff but we
also are lucky to have the chance to
make stuff that we are passionate about
that speaks to us that we want to get
out there and yeah that's what we're
going to continue to be doing or on
whether you marry Kish are going to
continue to be doing with the whole team
out there I'm the only one at this table
still working here today we had till
Friday we have about a little over 48
hours so let's just you know i mean it's
it's it's one of the reasons why I like
I mean I wanted to come on and talk
because I I think that um I couldn't be
happier with with my team with Mary and
and Rob and Aaron and Dan Ian and
jean-luc we brought on and all the new
guys that were bringing on as well Julie
who's up I don't know where what you're
doing right now but he's a good man
Cameron but that is like I i'm leaving i
feel like i'm leaving this team in a
good place to wear like I know that they
will make the best stuff out there and
you know it's tough right because like
you know it's it's really hard we have
to make content and we have to make sure
that you know we have to minimize
mistakes and other kind of stuff but for
the most part everyone here has a
passion for making content that they
care about that they hope our audience
cares about and and yeah you know it's I
feel good about where we are my whole
goal was to take people like Mary and
and and and some of the new people years
ago and just say hey you're going to be
the star you're going to be the face of
the site you're going to make the
content because I believe in you and I
know the audience will believe in you
too and my one if I take away anything
from this job it's just that I've had
awesome groups of people to like mentor
talk to Mary and I have gotten to maybe
only a few squabble here and there
because thankful just a few figurative
fight yes but only but it's what I value
value the people here though you're like
Mary and Danny and those guys like they
we have a good working relationship
where you know they're not afraid to
tell me how they feel I'm not afraid to
tell them how I feel and we work
together and
and it it's worked out and and that was
like with you when you were on my team
as well you know I mean I've talked to
you about hey you know like we can do
this we can do that like go go with this
you know you're good at this go take
care of it and do it go with air and
make the gun show it's [ __ ] rad you
know I love it you know so I mean it's
it's been awesome it's been fun ty route
we've been some lucky guys to work here
have we not oh this is been so rewarding
absolutely indeed and bittersweet to
sort of reflect on the past but exciting
times ahead for gamespot and so that's
what I would say to you folks is not
just thank you for watching and for
tuning in and for commenting and for
being a part of this community but you
know keep letting us know keep letting
these folks no hear how you're feeling
about things because we pay attention
and we listen and we learn and we evolve
and that is the story of GameSpot and
will continue to be the story of
GameSpot so stick around there's a lot
of incredible people here as you know
making some really cool stuff and we'll
see you all around and I guess that'll
that'll wrap it up ty Mary yeah yeah
this is really good it's good to kind of
have all these things in one one place
all my all the people i'm gonna miss in
one one place so I'm gonna miss both of
you guys very much I obviously can't
speak for anyone but myself but they're
all I could read and see you later yeah
they've all their the office is empty
we've already left for the day they
actually didn't even let me walk in the
building initially today they're like
well are you sure yeah she won't stop me
uh ty I realize I do want to talk about
their you going oh you're new out cuz I
mean you're not just you know you've got
a motivation to I am I I can't talk
about the company's surly right now but
what I can say is that I'm leaving games
leavin games yeah so my I've been doing
this 11 years Chris that's a lot and I
felt the need for a change not just a
change of a possible industry but also
change of scenery I'm returning to
austin texas austin texas where your
heart is that is my heart my heart is
the texan it is that was Eric take
calling you'll be a warriors fan Tay
don't worry um cuz
rants from so there you go yeah but um
yeah every time I tell people in
California I'm going to Texas they're
like horrified they're like why would
you do that no I've never been Austin
happy I'm like have you been Austin just
give it a chance I mean I know it's hot
as balls there but like you know it's
just a couple months out of the year
it's fine no problem anyways um yeah I'm
gonna be working at a tech startup that
specializes in a 360 view our video and
software so the future yes I hope ya
like it so yes that's the thing about
startups isn't it yes yes oh are you a
gambling man time basically yes yeah I
mean it was when I was one reason why I
wanted to come on and talk about it cuz
that's like you know it's it's it's just
a really good opportunity for me I feel
pretty good about my tenure here and I
felt it was the right time for me to try
something new you know with with no
dependents and and you know no family to
worry about this point I can take a
gamble like this and go so it was an
awesome opportunity presented itself at
the right time so I will miss all of you
terribly like the deserts miss the rain
very apt for the places you're going to
live yes ah ty thanks for sharing man
i'm really excited for you that is gonna
be really cool yeah definitely looking
forward to seeing how you get on down
Texas way i'll be keeping up keep in
touch keep in touch stay in the chats of
the shows hi Liz tweets alright folks if
you're sticking around this long you are
a true gamespot champ thank you for
bearing with us and really I have this
cool afternoon talking about gamespot
talking about the games we're currently
into and about the the place that this
place has been and the place that it
will be very very much a pleasure to
talk to you folks thank you thank you
and see you later